In three, two, one,
[Music]
action. This documentary covers a span
from the first coming of Jesus and what
was going on in the church up until just
before the second coming of Jesus. It
shows the great apostasy that crept into
the church and then ultimately the great
revival through the great
reformation. This is a life and death
battle. It's not just something that is
happening in hallucinations of a
prophet. Those things are played out in
real history.
[Music]
Pastor Doug Bachelor from Amazing Facts.
You're the president there. Thank you
for being on our show. Before we dive
into this topic, Revelation, the bride,
the beast in Babylon that your ministry
has made. Um, what is Amazing Facts?
What do you do there? Yeah. Well, the
the name Amazing Facts came from the we
started about 60 years ago with an idea
to do a radio program to try to share
truth with people. And we knew that
people were interested in an amazing
fact. So, we'd start with some amazing
fact from science or history or nature.
Then we'd segue into Bible teaching. And
uh so that's where the name comes from.
And the Lord's blessed, the ministry's
grown. Today we have uh training
programs all over the world. We do
radio, television, media, internet, and
um I've been with the ministry 30 years
this year. Wow. Wow. That's a long time.
So your your programs are also on some
major TV programs channels, right? Like
History Channel and some other ones.
Yeah, we're uh well actually on probably
about 50 different channels around the
world, but just in North America,
History, Lifetime, Day Star, ION,
Charge, Inspiration, 3ABN, TBN, Day
Star. Did I mention? Yeah. Family
Entertainment Television. So, we're on
quite a few networks in North America,
right? So, you don't sleep much?
No, they just duplicate tapes. It
doesn't take extra time for me. Nice.
No, I'm just curious. The the
Revelation, the bride, the beast in
Babylon, that's I think what how many
millions of views has it have on YouTube
right now? Like three or four million or
something like that. Am I correct? You
know, it's hard to tell because I know
one site has over three, but many people
have copied it and re-released it under
different titles and they get a lot of
views, too. So, it's hard to, you know,
you could add it up, but millions of
views anyway. Yeah. And I know a lot of
families sit there and do that as like a
form of worship and talk about it and
and discuss the material and stuff. So
it might not just be one person viewing
it. It might be a lot of people.
Exactly. Yeah. And DVD sales as well, of
course. Know I watched on DVD back in
the day.
Yeah. Yeah. I know. I've watched it.
I've watched it a few times. Yeah. It
was it was a really good uh documentary.
Well well made as well. Yeah. But for
those that aren't familiar and who
haven't seen it and don't know a lot
about what we're talking about, could
you tell us, Pastor Doug, give us a
quick synopsis of what Revelation, the
bride, the beast in Babylon is about.
Yeah. Well, I'll do my best. It's just
under an hour and uh we realize there's
a lot of confusion in the Christian
world about prophecy and we wanted to
break it down so that people could
understand it. And so using three
principal prophecies from like
Revelation 12:13, Revelation 17 where it
talks about these two women and the
beast. Um we show the panorama of church
history from the first coming of Jesus
to the second coming in a way that uh we
think everyone can understand it. And
you sit back and you go, "Wow, that's
exactly what happened." And u the Lord's
just blessed the project. You know, I
think a lot of people are scared of that
book and will will write to us and tell
us how confusing it is and we're kind of
pointing people back at your video
constantly. And um I I think people
don't realize though, it's a love story.
I mean, it's a simple love story of of
of God going after his church and then
it's like there's a dragon that's trying
to steal the woman to his side. And so
when you kind of look at it from that
perspective, I think it kind of helps
you approach it in a in a this is really
just imagery that's showing how much God
is is going after us. Yeah. I I remember
doing some evangelistic meetings on the
Navajo reservation
u 30 years ago and um this one couple
came in and they just looked terrified
because we had advertised we're talking
about Revelation and they told me
afterward our they said our pastor told
us not to come because there's a c curse
pronounced on people who study
Revelation. They were so afraid. Wow.
And I showed him I said no there's a
blessing pronounced. It's good. And he
says, "Blessed are those who read here
and keep the words." And the first
words, it's about Jesus. It's a
revelation. Yeah. Not of beasts, but
it's a revelation of Jesus. That's
right. So, you know, you can really see
the hero of the Bible best in
Revelation.
Amen. So, so pastor, there's so many
themes in the Bible that you could have
made a documentary about. Why this one?
Why Revelation? Why was this so
important to you that you had donors,
you know, uh, donate a lot of money to
this documentary and made one that,
praise God, has now has a lot of
millions of views? Why? Why? Why
Revelation? Yeah, good question. Um,
when I started reading Revelation, I
learned that out of the 404 verses in
Revelation, 278 approximately can be
found in the Old Testament. And so
Revelation is sort of like the cream of
the scriptures are are in there. There's
pieces of all the Bible in there. And so
by reading Revelation, you're getting
the themes of the whole Bible about the
battle between good and evil. So we
thought that would be a great
springboard to teach the gospel to show
this battle that goes on between good
and evil. And uh you know it does end
with good news. Yeah. I think it's a
cool way to present revelation because
again uh you mentioned pastor that some
people are afraid of studying it right
there's the curse or some people think
it's hard to understand and I've heard
other people saying that it's more of a
poetic book right but uh this
documentary kind of points out the
importance that is not only poetic but
it applies to us right now right and I
know there are other documentaries that
amazing facts has made as well. Um like
uh cosmic conflict. I think that was
another one that was really well made
talking about the uh the creation of the
world and the war in heaven also
mentioned in Revelation 12, right? And
yeah, I think it was uh really cool to
um like attack this issue that is
something that we need to study today.
prophecy. Um, it's a great place to
start because it's like how how
impossible would it be to guess the
future. I mean, that that just doesn't
there's no way you could tell who who's
going to be on top and you know, even
probably 10 years from now. So, I think
when you win their confidence with that,
I think it's a it's their hearts are
open to listen. I'm I'm currently going
through um Daniel 8 and N. Um, you know,
I've heard this so many times in
prophecy seminars and and I studied it
like years ago, but I wanted to go
through it again just verse by verse.
And it is amazing how this time prophecy
um of the 2,300 days in total and
there's different segments of other time
prophecies in between how you can if you
have just one date wrong, everything
falls apart. So there's like there's no
way then if it all be is fulfilled that
you have to have every single date
correct. And the whole time prophecy
points to Jesus to his coming and to you
know um to our time today and and how we
should be living today and and even
Jesus ministry in heaven right now. It's
phenomenal and I think this just
strengthens your faith and Daniel goes
handinhand with revelation.
So, pastor, how how is what's the key to
unlock this? How are you uh able to to
see and find out these things for our
viewers that you know might think that
that Revelation is kind of a scary book?
Like what's how are you uncovering what
it actually is saying or meaning? Yeah.
Uh another good question. Um well, first
of all, I I don't, you know, have any
kind of magic interpretation skills. I'm
standing on the shoulders of great
Protestant scholars that have looked at
the parallels in the Bible and prophecy
is not that difficult. First of all, God
wants us to understand prophecy. Let me
say that. Uh you know, the very name
Revelation means a revealing. So the
idea that it's a mystery, we're not
supposed to
understand yet Jesus tells us to read it
and there's a blessing. uh he doesn't
say you'll understand it all in one day
but he does want us to understand it
because why say it the first thing Jesus
does when he rises from the dead he
appears to two disciples on the road to
Emmas this is in Luke 24 and it says
beginning at Moses and all the prophets
he expounded unto them in all the
scriptures the things concerning himself
so the first sermon Jesus gives when he
rises from the dead is explaining Bible
prophecy Y and then later he meets in
the upper room and he explains the
prophecies and Paul the early church
when he went from one sing synagogue to
the next talking to the Jews he would
show them from the prophecies that Jesus
was the Messiah. So the the conversion
potential of prophecy is enormous. So
that's one reason. Um but the as far as
what the symbolism meant for example you
know we we've got two prominent women in
revelation. You got one in Revelation
12. Pure woman. She's clothed with
light. The dragon is angry at her. Well,
what does that mean? Well, Jesus said to
the church, "You are the light of the
world." And the Bible says that the
church is the bride of Christ. Husbands,
love your wives as Christ loves the
church. So, a woman could represent the
church. But then, Revelation 17, you've
got an unfaithful church who's
committing adultery. Well, this
describes what's happened to God's
people many times in the Old Testament
when they went after
idolatry. Well, that's what happened to
the church after Christ during the um
the you know Roman Catholic era. They
fell into worshiping the Roman idols and
she's portrayed as an unfaithful woman.
And then it tells us who the dragon is.
It says that dragon, the serpent, and uh
the devil. There's no confusing who he
is.
So, Revelation is kind of giving us the
keys that the dragon wants to destroy
the woman of light and the woman in
Revelation 17 is riding on the dragon.
They're in cooperation. So, you you just
start giving common sense explanations
and you can use the Old Testament to
show what the symbols are and the lights
begin to pop on and you say, "Wow, yeah,
that all makes sense." So, you just have
to fill in the the uh the symbols, the
coloring so to speak with the follow the
numbers. You can tell what these
different symbols mean and it tells a
story about a battle. Yeah. The Bible
often interprets itself. And so, you
know, you don't have to necessarily go
outside of that to get that
understanding if you just, you know,
read read the Bible in its entirety.
Sometimes there's those books that
people will skip over and it's hard to
tell what's going on if you're kind of
missing information. Yeah. A lot of
times it's a few verses later that the
symbols interpreted. Yeah. H have have
you had um you know other churches kind
of contact you or have some discussion
about like uh you know a real difference
of opinion on those things? Yeah. Well,
you know, if you look online, you'll see
that there's actually one or two
YouTubes or websites that are dedicated
to saying this is why Amazing Facts and
the bride the beast in Babylon is all
wrong. Mhm. And you know I I respect
that because there are four major views
of prophecy. We are taking what you call
the historist view. Yeah. So when people
approach the prophecies especially
revelation you've got what they call the
predtoist view and you can kind of tell
from the name predtor means pre. They
basically believe that most of the
prophecies of revelation were talking
about other than you know heaven at the
very end of the book that the you the
beast and all that is talking about the
battle between Nero and the Christians
and the Jews that all was concluded
pretty much in the first century. So
they're looking at revelation as though
it's all past. Those are the predtoists.
Then you got a group that's fairly new.
I mean compared to Christian history,
futurism is is a fairly new view. It
really began with a Catholic priest
named a Jesuit priest named Francisco
Rivera. Well, there's a couple of
Predist view or futurist views, but he's
one. And he basically, you know, when
the reformation started pointing to the
Catholic Church and saying that this is
Revelation 17, this is the woman uh sits
among seven hills. They said that's Rome
and that the beast is the pope, the
antichrist rather. And that was the view
of Spurgeon and Luther and Whitfield and
Wesley and they all believed that going
all the way back to you know uh Jean Hus
and and um the Walansies. So that was a
that was a historic view. But people
began to leave the Catholic Church in
flux. And so the Jesuits, they basically
said, "We better give another
explanation." And so Francisco Rivera
concocted a interpretation of prophecy
called futurism. That when Revelation 4
when it says John hears a voice and a
trumpet, that trumpet is the
resurrection. That's a secret rapture of
the church. The church is called away.
And they say everything from Revelation
4 onward that would normally point to
the Catholic Church during its long
history, that's all still in the future.
And they talk about, you know, the seven
years of tribulation which are not
mentioned in Revelation. So there's this
whole secret rapture left behind
scenario. It was started out by a
Catholic Jesuit, adopted by Campbell and
put in the Scoffield Bible who was a
Protestant and then made famous by Hal
Lindsay with late great planet earth and
others and then Tim Lehei writing in the
left behind series and now you can even
see where Billy Graham near the end of
his life began to recognize that view
where before he was a histo.
So futurism is taking everything from
Revelation 4 onward and it puts it
pretty much in the
future. But the the the view that really
stands up the best would be histom.
Jesus said the things that I'm telling
you they'll begin to come to pass.
Revelation is giving the history of the
church. You the Lord was telling them
ahead of time what was going to happen
beginning with the first coming of Jesus
up to the second coming and the earth
made new. So it completes the story and
he uses several visions just like Daniel
tells the same history with different
visions. You got, you know, the metal
image and you got the ram and the goat
and you got the lion and the bear and
the leopard and the nondescript beast.
So all covering the same history in
Daniel. Revelation does the same thing.
You've got kind of the political history
of the church in the seven seals. You
have the religious history of the church
in the seven churches, Revelation 2 and
three. and you've got the military
history and the seven trumpets. And so
God is just giving this panorama of
church history and that works. It fits.
It lines up. But obviously people that
believe predtoism and um futurism,
they're going to be threatened by that.
And so they're going to try to undermine
it, which is expected. And I should say
in fairness, there's a fourth view which
is called idealism. That's people who
they say, "Well, Revelation is really
written with spiritual lessons for all
people. They don't try to pin it to any
time in history. They just say that, you
know, it talks about the the moral
lessons of good and evil and it's a sort
of idealism. It's it's sort of a very
ethereal jello form of interpretation.
Hey, subscribe
to Latina. If you want to learn Spanish,
a great way will be watching our videos
for
practice. So, when we look at the book
of Revelation and and and we see in the
beginning it's about Jesus Christ. John
opens with that. But so many people when
they approach the book, they want to
know about another figure. They don't
want to know about Jesus Christ. They're
concerned about Antichrist. So when you
look at the book of Revelation and it
identifies the antichrist and it and it
identifies uh worship and false worship,
how do we know that at the end of time
that this the antichrist, the mark of
the beast, all of this is about worship?
Revelation as I mentioned is the key is
look back. So when you read about an
image to the beast and those that don't
worship will be killed. A good Bible
student immediately knows Daniel chapter
3 king makes an image. Those that don't
worship the image should be killed.
There's a you see you go back there. You
say Mark if you you everyone's going to
have a mark and the one who has the
wrong mark persecutes the one who has
the right mark. You go to Cain and Abel
goes all the way back. They're both
claiming to worship the same God. Uh but
one kills the other even though they're
brothers. So people who take the name of
Christ in the last days, Jesus said,
"The hour is coming in which those that
kill you will think they're serving
God." Like Paul, he thought he was
serving God. So it's telling us the same
old story is going to be repeated in the
last days. And but Jesus is the theme.
The last books in last verses in the
Bible is even so come Lord Jesus, you
know. So, it begins the revelation of
Jesus. He's the one riding on the white
horse. He's the king of kings. He's the
word of God. He's the lamb slain in the
middle of the throne. Matter of fact,
Christ has more names in Revelation than
anywhere else in the Bible. He's the
alpha and the omega. He's the beginning
and the end. And um like I said, King of
Kings and Lord and Lords all the way
through the book. It's about Jesus. But
it does not neglect that there's an
enemy. It does not neglect there's a
great battle sometimes called the battle
of
Armageddon and uh but Christ is going to
be victorious. It's really almost like
they're separating everybody on the
planet into two camps, right? You're
either totally on God's side or by
default if you're not on God's side,
you're you're on the other side. And so,
you know, God never does anything before
telling us what he's going to do. That
would be really random if God just, you
know, made the end time people go
through this horrible experience and not
give them anything like the end of the
story. And so that's comforting to me to
know that God is like spelt out what's
going to happen. That way we can
prepare. We can learn about it. We can
teach others about it and and make sure
everybody knows what those two choices
are. Who do you really worship? The God
of this world or the God of heaven.
Yeah. Mhm. And with with all of these
terms in Revelation, you know, when
people think of
Revelation, I think four things mainly
point out stand out for the the common
person that hasn't read the book, they
think Revelation is about the end of the
world, you got the mark of the beast,
you got the famous number of men, aka
the 666, and the antichrist, right? All
these things people uh it's what they
focus on is what they focus on in you
know movies and media. You got a movie
called Armageddon. You know a bunch of
movies about uh the end of the world.
The mark of the beast is a ship. Is it
the the chip is the vaccine? What is it?
Right. So what what do is all is like
there's all these counterfeits that the
devil makes out there of the different
meanings of these things in revelation.
How does that impact people from
actually understanding the real meaning
of what who the antichrist is? What is
the mark of the beast? You know what is
the Armageddon? Is the end of the world
something that we should fear the way
that is portrayed out there? Is it
something that that we should worry
about or not? Yeah. Well, you've touched
on several important points there and so
I could launch into into a number of
directions. First, they'll say God
doesn't want us to worry. I I sleep at
night. I don't worry about the beast and
I don't worry about Armageddon. Um, I
will mention, I hope you'll forgive me
for this plug, but amazing facts, our
current project that we've been working
on for four years now is a movie
documentary called Armageddon: The Final
Events of Prophecy. You probably saw
years ago, we did one called The Final
Events. It was in standard definition.
It was very, you know, very low budget.
We're doing something now that's much
better and it's a little more expanded,
but that should be out this year. Well,
maybe we'll talk more about that when
it's released, but um yeah, people have
the wrong idea about what Armageddon is.
And suppose that there is a true
interpretation of Revelation. If you
were the devil, you would want to create
a lot of counterfeit interpretations to
throw people off the track, which is one
reason we made the bride, the beast, and
the Babylon is there's so many people
out there that are confused. Now, with
some prophecy, there's a couple
different kinds of prophecy. Jesus said
some prophecy when it happens then you
will believe. Mhm. In other words, we
say, "Oh, wow. Look at that. It happened
just like he foretold." And so the
prophecy is redeeming us because we say,
"Hey, God's word can be trusted." But
with Revelation, you can't wait until it
comes to pass before you believe. It's
one of those prophecies God is saying,
"I'm telling you in advance, so you will
prepare in advance." So, I think people
recognize that Revelation's different in
that sense in that God says those that
get the mark of the beast, um there's no
redemption for them. In fact, the worst
plagues that are ever pronounced in the
Bible fall on the ones that get the mark
of the beast. So, I think that's one
reason people are so afraid. But it's a
prophecy that God wants us to understand
in advance or it's fatal, unlike other
prophecies where you look back and say,
"Wow, that's just what God said." Pastor
Doug, um there are uh people who might
be concerned that they're going to
wander after false prophets, false
prophecies. I mean, there's so many
people out there today who say, I am a
prophet, and they make statements that
seem to be coming true. How can these
people have the assurance that, you
know, hey, there's like 50 different
flavors of the mark of the beast. This
is the right one. You know, and like you
said, one thing you said already is
obviously the fulfillment of it. Yeah.
Well, that's that's so important. That's
why Jesus said uh there's going to be
many false Christs, many false prophets
in the last days. The first thing he
said when he explains the last days,
many false prophets will arise, many
will say, "I am Christ." Uh and
basically, we need to know the word so
that we can separate the wheat from the
chaff. Um he says, "If any man speaks
not according to this word, this is
Isaiah 8 16 and 20, there's no light in
them." So when we measure these
different interpretations or people
claiming to be Christ by the word of
God, uh the deceptions are going to be
so compelling that if it were possible,
the elect would be deceived. But the
elect are they're saturated with the
word. And so they're going to spot the
counterfeit. And that's the key is we we
need to know the word. And um it'll all
fit. And you know, God gives us evidence
so we can know how to interpret a
prophecy accurately. I think God is very
merciful because he's laid out all the
issues in his word. And when we see all
these things in in Revelation that seem
seem scary, it reminds me of Deuteronomy
where, you know, God is telling the
children of Israel, you know, I've set
before you life and death, blessing and
cursing. And he tells them, choose life.
And and that's essentially what
Revelation is doing as well. It's
setting all the issues on the table. And
and Christ is telling us, choose life.
You know, I've told you how it's going
to end and you have the opportunity to
choose. So, choose life. Yeah. There's a
call there's a calling, you know, that
that you hear in Revelation like come
out come out of the systems of this
world and the and the brokenness and and
and be separate. Don't be a partaker of
her sins. Can you kind of explain that a
little bit and and sort of break that
down? Yeah. Um, Revelation is calling
for people to um be willing to follow
where the lamb leads. It talks about
this group, the
144,000, and it says, "These are they.
They are not defiled with women." Not
saying they're physical virgins, cuz the
women it's talking about are Babylon and
her daughters. They are not defiled with
the false teachings of Babylon and her
daughters that are in Revelation 17. But
they follow the lamb wherever he goes.
They're not following the world. They're
not following the crowd. Uh Revelation
17 describes the counterfeit
uh the beast power and that woman. It
says with whom the kings of the earth
have committed fornication. It's it and
it talks about when the plagues come
that Babylon is so concerned about the
material loss of wealth, all of the gold
and the silver and the pearls and the
souls of men. And and so it's basically
saying those that are following Christ
are not following the treasures of the
world. They're not following the idols
of the world. They're following Christ
and they're following the lamb, which is
one of self-sacrifice. Mhm. They love
not their lives even unto death. Amen.
You know, it's like they're completely
sold out to Christ. And it doesn't
matter what you can't, you know, take
their soul. You could take their body,
but you, you know, they they are that
dedicated to God. I was just going
through Hebrews 11 that talks about all
of these people who are like tortured,
you know, they were in the caverns,
which is what Revelation the the beast
in Babylon talks about as well during
the Roman times, how these Christians
were tortured and they were underground,
had their own tunnel systems and stuff.
And I mean, they went through everything
and they and then it's and it wraps it
up with, you know, they're they're
resting until Jesus comes back. And when
he comes back, they have the better
future, the hope of glory that they had
all along. like you said, they didn't
love their lives unto the death. And
that's something that we need to be
ready for, prepared for as well. When
this mark of the beast comes and the
final battle happens that we say you
can, you know, take this off and it
doesn't matter. I will rather die for
the Lord knowing there's going to be a
resurrection to everlasting life. Amen.
Bud has asked his people to be faithful
and leave the results to him
essentially. Yeah. Why why does it
always talk about Babylon? Um what what
Babylon we know doesn't exist right now
today. So why is Revelation always kind
of pointing people back down to Babylon?
Yeah, a good question. And that's
another place where going back in the
Bible gives us a lot of context is you
know you've got uh Nimrod who was a
mighty hunter against God. Basically he
was something of a rebel, one of the
first kings. He builds the first kingdom
of Babel. And then later, you know, you
get to Revelation 11, they've got the
tower of Babel. Uh God said to go
scatter and fill the earth and they
refuse to do that. And he says he'll
never flood the world again. And they're
kind of thinking, well, just in case we
can't trust them, we better build a
tower that reaches to heaven. It's like
we're going to work our way to heaven.
Babylon becomes a symbol of and then it
says let us make a name for ourselves
not for God but for ourselves. So Bab
Babylon is the epitome of man-made
religion, man-made
salvation. And it is contrasted through
the Bible to Jerusalem. You know, you've
got a little town called Salem where
Melkisedc was the king. And then you got
Babel where you had Nimrod. And from
those two symbols they grow into
Jerusalem and Babylon. Babylon conquers
Jerusalem. And um uh you know at one
time the ambassadors from Babylon come
to Hezekiah and instead of glorifying
God, he glorifies himself. And God says
everything you have is going to go to
Babylon. Babylon is also Mesopotamia.
And just keep this in mind. Abraham came
out of Mesopotamia. Abraham brought his
wife from Babylon to the promised land.
Then you got the other patriarch, Isaac.
God says to Abraham, "Don't let him get
a local girl. He sends his servant back
to Mesopotamia to bring a bride,
Rebecca, out of Babylon into the
promised land." And Jacob goes back and
he gets four for the price of one. He
ends up with his wives that he brings
out of Babylon into the promised land.
And then you have God's people are
carried to Babylon and they have a
priest named Joshua that brings them out
of Babylon and along with Ezra and
Nehemiah back to the promised land. So
now in the last days, God's people are
scattered around the world and being
persecuted by Babylon, but they're being
brought back to the truth, his bride, uh
the new Jerusalem, um which is the the
new promised land. So you got the
symbolism through the Bible. Babylon
becomes synonymous just like the devil
is synonymous with a serpent or the
serpent with the devil. Babylon sort of
becomes a symbol for the the rebellion
that is in opposition to God.
Good point. Yeah. I you just did a a
series in New York and uh how'd that go
over? Well, it was very exciting. That
was uh the 25th anniversary of the net
99 meetings that we had done on same
building except this time we went to the
bigger venue.
And we sort of were reversing the
cursing of Babel because you know in
Babylon all the languages were cursed.
At the Prophecy Odyssey meetings in New
York City, we were one of the first who
utilized AI to take the messages and it
basically captured my voice and then it
uh translated the messages and you can
go to the site and you just pick your
language and you can hear me preach the
same sermon in Mandarin and Hindi and
German and Spanish and Portuguese. So,
it's really amazing the technology now.
So, it went very well. It's had 45
million views on the Facebook and
YouTube and um it was very exciting. We
praise God for that. You know, I think I
think it's awesome that you you chose
New York because a lot of times when we
think of mission work, we think like,
you know, going over to some overseas
third world country, but we have people
right here in our home that are in a
spiritual desert. And uh they're just
they're not fed with or don't have the
opportunities to learn, you know, the
the truths. And so it's neat to see your
ministry really embrace that and just,
you know, herald by going out in the
middle of middle of one of our greatest
cities in our country. Yeah. And when
you go to New York, because it is a
cosmopolitan city, you have people from
every country there now. Well, I grew up
I used to live in New York City and you
know, we got a neighborhood, you cross
the street, you go from Germany to
Italy, you cross another street and
you're in Chinatown. So it's sort of if
you do a meeting in New York, it's
relevant for people around the world.
You guys are in media and you know that
New York City has been destroyed by
Godzilla, King Kong, asteroids, tsunami,
aliens, you name it. I have thought it'd
be fun to do a composite video sometime
of how many times New York gets
destroyed. Be very interesting. You
probably have to pay for that footage to
do that, but it'd be it'd be really
funny. So, we thought it'd be good to go
to New York and encourage them a little.
Well, thank you, pastor, for doing that.
And uh where where can people see
Prophecy Odyssey and where can I see
Revelation of the Bride, the beast in
Babylon? Yeah, thanks. The um Prophecy
Odyssey uh of course all you do is type
in Prophecy Odyssey will be posted at
the website. People can still watch it
for free. The programs are being edited
now for our national broadcast. They're
broken into half, you know, our national
programs are only half an hour. It's
about all we can afford. So we break
them in half. We offer the lessons.
They'll be appear in March, what we did
in New York. And um you know, one thing
I want to close with, if it's okay with
you, Yeah. everything we've said about
Revelation and the bride beast in
Babylon is it's a it has a happy ending.
Mhm. You know, it it I love the part
where it says there is no more pain.
There is no more suffering. People think
of Revelation and they think of all the
scary part, the most beautiful promises
in the Bible. No more tears in heaven up
where God has restored the Garden of
Eden. There's no more death. And and so
Revelation has got some of the best news
in the Bible. And um so people should
Yeah. It's got a tough section, but it
ends with it's a happy ending. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Yeah. It's all worth it in
the end. But yeah. Yeah. So, Revelation,
the bride, the beast in Babylon on
YouTube and I'm guessing on
afbookstore.com for a DVD copy of it.
Yeah. If anyone still has a DVD player.
Yeah, they can still buy the DVDs. Uh I
asked for a show of hands this week. How
many people had a DVD player at a camp
meeting? I think three people raised
their hand.
So, but you know, it's it's available
online and you can share with your
friends through a jump drive or whatever
or send them a link and um but yeah, we
we want to get the word out and I thank
you folks for what you do and and this
program. Yeah. Awesome. Praise God. But
I also want to let the viewers know at
home know that we also have a video on
our channel about um what who the
antichrist is, what is the mark of the
beast, who did the pilgrims believe the
uh antichrist was, and uh you know what
what's the uh pagan bale origins of 666
if that's what you're into. And
obviously also make sure you hit
subscribe to Amazing Facts. Check out
their channel. They're doing amazing
stuff. Prophecy Odyssey link in the
description and also for Revelation the
bride the beast in Babylon. If you like
this video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comment
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]